[Music]
there's a Stillness in Soul
a quiet shock
horror hanging in the air
a Halloween celebration in it Taiwan
that became a crippling Crush killing
more than 150 people
Joel Jang was there haunted by what he
saw
it's just like a joke I don't think
you're such a festival there would be
some young people just like me died
oh [ __ ] inside
I saw somebody
lying on the road and they were watching
the costume
for families the weight of the loss was
unbearable
[Applause]
this is what their loved ones faced
people rammed together Emergency
Services trying to pull people free
partygoers piled on top of each other a
situation that suddenly spiraled
you can see traces of the panic
everywhere the harrowing Rush what
strikes you most about this space is
just how narrow it is it's easy to
imagine how difficult it would have been
for people to escape and for help to
reach them there were a hundred thousand
people in this area it became a scene of
bewildering and devastating chaos
[Music]
this was Next Level shoulder to shoulder
front to back just shimmying along on
those streets oh no control about where
you're going to move at times
[Applause]
Janelle caught the moment things turned
oh my God oh my God my God
you feel there was simply too many
people for such a small space
the city knows people come to itawan for
Halloween they know that there's going
to be flocks to people they've been
reporting about it earlier in the week
saying each one's Racing for the
Halloween events this weekend you know
100 000 people
they knew so where was the crowd control
South Korea's government has said a
considerable number of police and
security forces were deployed
but it was not enough to save so many
young lives the nation now submerged in
mourning
Cordelia Lynch Sky News it Taiwan South
Korea